hey I've talked about Saudi Arabia many
many times Saudi Arabia is one of the
closest allies of the United States it
is one of the most extreme religious
regimes authoritarian religious regimes
in the world it is similar to Hamas in
many ways where women must have in Saudi
Arabia the consent of a male guardian to
travel abroad they often need permission
to work or study a woman must have
permission from her father brother or
other male relative in the case of a
widow sometimes it's from her own son to
obtain a passport to leave the country
many workplaces and universities demand
that a woman have a Guardians consent
just to be employed at the University or
to have a to be a student at the
University although that's not legally
required if you rent an apartment or you
want to get treatment at the hospital
you often are also required to have your
male Guardians permission well there are
at least some women in Saudi Arabia who
want to change this 14000 Saudi women at
least 14,000 Saudi women have signed a
petition calling for an end to the male
guardianship system this is good news I
unfortunately don't know whether
anything will really change number one
will the government listen to a petition
from 14,000 women I don't know
I'm skeptical about that but number two
as we've talked about with the burqa
there are very very conspicuous loud
boisterous advocates of the male
guardianship system in Saudi Arabia that
are women and we've said yes sometimes
you hear well the women want the burqa
well they want it because they actually
have really considered in a serious
manner what the burqa represents and
what it means and the implications of it
or they want it because from the time
they were born they were raised in a
society where the burqa is described it
is associated with morals and ethics and
the right social order
so I have significant doubts that this
is really going to achieve anything I
think it is fantastic that even 14
thousand women were willing to sign this
petition because we know that political
activism in Saudi Arabia is very very
often punished this is by no means a
foreign concept to the United States
this idea that there are some women who
say no actually the male Guardians a
guardianship system is good if you go
back to the 20s when we had women's
right to vote working its way through
the country for approval there were anti
suffrage organizations of women they had
different reasons for opposing of female
suffrage some said well listen were kind
of in a situation of domestic privilege
if all of a sudden we're really equal we
might have to be out there working in
some of those very physically demanding
jobs that right now we are exempt from
that is a very popular argument that
I've heard from some men's rights
activists but the the point that I'm
trying to make is you will very often
have when you are trying to move away
from the status quo a group of
individuals that from the outside we
would see and say well why wouldn't
women want the right to vote
why wouldn't Saudi women want to end the
male guardianship system so that they
could actually have agency and equality
under the law to make decisions for
themselves
it's nothing new it even existed here in
the United States during the 1920s
during the women's suffrage movement and
of course any time we talk about this
vile stuff going on in Saudi Arabia I'm
reminded of the disgusting nature of
this buddy-buddy alliance between the
United States and Saudi Arabia an
alliance that is vile and despicable and
really should not exist full stop